the cdc just approved a third vaccine
for all eligible americans the agency is
calling for boosters eight months after
people get their second pfizer or
moderna shot the doses could begin as
soon as september 20th and that's just a
month away bianca holman explains what
this means for you at home
well across the valley there are pop-up
vaccine clinics like this one right here
at city hall and come september there
could be more of these around town with
people getting their third dose the cdc
shares that it's now very clear that
immunity starts to fall after the two
the first two initial doses with the
spread of the delta variant and
breakthrough cases is important to
protect people against extreme
complications you may remember the fda
first approved a third shot for
americans with weakened immune systems
like those with cancer hiv or organ
transplants now the cdc has cleared a
third dose of the pfizer and moderna
vaccine eight months after the second
dose pfizer said a small study showed
people with a third dose had higher
levels of antibodies including against
the delta variant
that third dose is not necessarily a
booster it's actually a third dose of
the same vaccine that's already been
received just to help to help improve
the immune response that those
individuals might might have
so the shot will be typically given at
doctors offices pharmacies or the health
district and will most likely be on an
honor system now when it comes back to
the johnson and johnson vaccine that has
not yet been approved for a second shot
remember it's only one so it hasn't been
approved for a second shot yet there's
still some data and research that needs
to be done reporting from city hall
bianca holmen 8 news now